it was announced this week that the man
affectionately known as mr potato head
brian stelter is leaving cnn first we
lost tubin now we're losing stelter cnn
reports cnn's reliable sources with
brian stelter is coming to an end the
company announced thursday that it's
ending the media analysis show that has
aired in various iterations for 30 years
its last episode will be this sunday as
a result brian stelter will leave the
company a cnn spokesperson told cnn
business so they're they're pretending
that they're not firing him it's just
that the show's going away it was an
interesting choice first of all that
they chose to announce the end of brian
stelter's show like this because if they
hadn't said anything at all nobody would
have ever known stelter is like the guy
in office space who was fired from his
job but remained on the staff for like
five years and nobody ever realized he
was laid off five years ago and no one
ever told him about it brian stelter is
milton he's the milton of cable news
anyway now stelter is unemployed also
looking for new opportunities